[Music]
yeah
accidental touch turned into a gentle
against subtle
Kiki Palmer welcomes her first child
with boyfriend Darius Jackson you
already know over on the gram she breaks
down their Whirlwind new lives as mom
and dad to son leotis first up a
couple's pick quote only 48 Hours of
being parents
[Music]
then it's on to a car ride sing-along
of me
[Music]
[Applause]
your girl is ready for the park Kiki
explains Darius always made me playlists
when we first started dating someone by
El DeBarge was a favorite we became each
other someone and made a someone as she
tells it that someone's also loving
rolling Ray of course I stopped it I
stopped it is
a lot of chaos for me because the baby
love rolled away
after joking about whether fans will see
the newborn's face
hiki shows leotis getting his nap on oh
my gosh come on let's talk about it the
actress wraps up her caption born during
Black History Month with a name to match
leotis and relton Jackson welcome to the
world baby Leo people have been in my
comments saying Kiki's having a baby
Kiki's pregnant this comes roughly three
months after leotis made his TV debut
and I want to set the record straight I
am
when his mom shocked fans with a baby
bump reveal on Saturday Night Live this
has been the biggest blessing and I am
so excited guys I'm gonna be a mom
you have a respect sister of course
those in Kiki's Inner Circle like Lonnie
love learned the good news ahead of time
I was like okay you know Auntie Lottie
go be quiet but I just love the way that
she did it and we're just so happy for
her and she's happy and healthy and
that's what matters congratulations Kiki
[Music]
as long as